[MUSIC]
[FOREIGN] You are an 18 year old high
school
exchange student in a small Bavarian town.
You've been invited on a congressional
delegation to Berlin, Germany.
And you are the youngest person there by
at least 30 years.
You're wearing a business suit for
the first time ever you're feeling pretty
good.
[LAUGH] And so you raise your hand and you
ask the Congressman.
[FOREIGN].
What are your foreign policy goals?
And as the words confidently come out of
your mouth, you hear the audience gasp.
[LAUGH]
Today,
I wanna speak to you about how language
shapes us and our relationships.
In our globalized world,
people are to connect between far corners
of this planet.
And as English becomes the [INAUDIBLE]
every day, more and
more of these conversations are happening
in a common language.
But what happens when people begin
communicating
in a language that is not their own.
A lot get's lost in translation.
A lot more then just words.
Our values, our beliefs and our norms are
embedded in our language.
But it goes a step further, our language
influences how we see the world and
what we think about it.
By not fully appreciating the importance
of language,
are we short-changing relationships?
So as I crouched back in those
congressional chambers with 50 sets of
eyes staring at me, I wondered, what did I
do wrong?
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> I replayed the words in my head.
What are your foreign policy goals?
Couldn't figure it out.
What are your for,
[SOUND] [FOREIGN] I duted the congressman.
I committed the cardinal sin of all German
language learners.
You see in German, just as in French or
Spanish, there are two versions of
the second person pronoun, you, du and
Sie, the informal and the formal.
I had learned this rule many times before,
but
I just glossed over those pages in my
textbooks.
[LAUGH] I didn't understand why I should
have to address someone differently
just because they were older than me.
[LAUGH] What I didn't realize was that in
ignoring this rule
I was ignoring an important social norm of
respect and hierarchy.
As I addressed my congressman with the
informal due,
I offended him his office his reputation
and all 50 adults staring at me.
By ignoring the importance of language,
I missed an opportunity to form a
meaningful relationship.
Now, speaking of meaningful relationships,
how many of you remember the first time
you met your in-laws?
Scary, right?
[LAUGH]
My fiance Alex
came with me to visit my extended family
in Belgrade,
Serbia, the city in which I was born,
about a year into our relationship.
The day we landed I took him to my
favorite outdoor cafe and
as we sipped on an iced tea, he asked me.
So what, who exactly are we meeting
tomorrow?
I started telling that to all my aunts and
uncles.
I was so excited for it to him to meet but
he interrupted me,
how are your related to all of these
people?
[LAUGH]
I grabbed a napkin and a pen and
I started drawing my family tree.' Well
you see,
tomorrow: we're going to hang out with my
mom's side of the family.
I love her, aunt and uncle basically
raised her.
Slap that on the docket.
And then her kids Sally and Sandra.
And then their kids Mija, [UNKNOWN] and
Mijalid they're just like this to us.
And the next day we're gonna hang out with
my dad's side of the family.'.
Because my, my grandfather on my dad side,
he had four siblings.
And all of them have obviously aunts,
there's aunts and uncles, and
then cousins and I then I guess grand
cousins,
I'm not really sure what you call it.
Many of them leave in Boston and Toronto,
but they're all here for the summer.
[LAUGH] And then next week, we're gonna go
Eastern Serbia,
we're gonna have my mom's side of the
family.
That grandfather had three siblings, so
there's a lot of them over there as well.
[LAUGH]
So, as I rattled off my family tree.
I realized how much was lost in
translation.
In Serbian, I have words to describe if my
aunts and uncles are from my maternal or
paternal side.
If they're related by blood or marriage.
Chinese even has words to describe the
relative birth order
of your aunts and uncles.
But in English, I only have two words aunt
and uncle.
Embedded in our language are our values.
And if sharing and understanding one
another's values is one of the bedrocks
of, of meaningful relationships, are we
missing an opportunity?
Alex's immediately family means the world
to him.
But I couldn't imagine a world without my
Serbian version
of My Big Fat Greek Wedding.
[LAUGH] As I translated my family try to
him in English,
my value of extended family and community
was lost in translation.
Fully understanding our values is
critical.
If we truly want to understand each other
are we missing an opportunity by not
fully understanding how language shapes
us?
Whether you're navigating you in-law's
family tree or
a multi-national corporation's org
structure,
you might be able to learn something about
the pe-, about what matters to the people
around you by understanding the words they
would use to describe their worlds.
Now I have a question for all of you.
How would you describe the following
situation?
Oh!
Shit!
[LAUGH]
Sorry about that.
Now, imagine I broke the glass.
How would describe what just happened?
English speakers, are more likely to say
Helena broke the glass.
Where Spanish and Japanese speakers are
most likely to see the glass broke itself,
said [FOREIGN]
[LAUGH].
How do you think the way you answer that
question
impacts the way you see the world?
The cognitive scientist who ran the
initial glass experiment at Stanford found
out that when a glass was broken by
accident, English speakers were more
likely to remember who broke the glass
than Spanish or Japanese speakers.
They were more likely to assign agency to
an individual even in the event of
an accident, this has massive implications
on society.
Our language impacts how we see the world,
how we think about our relationships to
each other, to our government, how we
interpret financial crises.
I understand that there's a chicken and
egg problem here.
Does language create culture or does
culture create language?
I am not gonna venture to answer that
question today,
I will leave that to the linguists.
[LAUGH] The simple fact,
is that two people can interpret the exact
same event in two completely
different ways simply because of how they
formulate their sentences.
By not fully appreciating how language
shapes our world view and
that of others, are we short-changing
relationships?
So when I think back to my 18 year old
self, confidently raising my hand and
anciently duding my congressman,
I realized how lucky I was to have
offended them and make that mistake.
Time and time again, I have seen how
language how our values, our norms,
and our beliefs are embedded in and shaped
by our val, by our language.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Many of us will go on to live in a
globalized world.
But each and
every one of us will continue to form
relationships across cultural ties.
So I'd encourage you, just as I did, to
stop thinking about those rules
as being frustrating things you have to
learn in class, to learning more of them.
I've gone from seeing language as a
barrier to building relationships,
to seeing it as an opportunity to deepen
them.
So next time you are feeling pretty good.
Raising her hand, I'm ready to ask that
question.
[LAUGH] Ask yourself first.
How does language shape me and how do I
wanna use it to shape my relationships?
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]